[Music]
HBO has just dropped a watchman teaser
trailer and whilst the footage is
relatively short that's still a lot to
unpack from it in the footage we see
mask policeman covered in the infamous
watchman smiley face yellow to me this
signifies that since the events of the
original booth that police have had to
escalate their dealings and become one
with the vigilantes requiring masks in
order to operate slightly above the law
this was a huge aspect of why the
Minutemen in the original graphic novel
chose to mask up and night-owl himself
started off as a policeman so this is
quite an interesting take we are then
shown plain cold svigel auntie's who may
be continued in the work of the watchman
or may in fact be policemen who still
wish to operate outside the law Jeremy
Irons can be seen and he is playing the
role of Ozymandias who states it's only
just begun this of course ties into the
line from the watchman of nothing ever
ends which is uttered by dr. Manhattan
toss him and Dyess after his plan comes
to fruition whether he has been
discovered or not like in Doomsday Clock
seems unclear but we do get another tie
back to that book with a new Rorschach
in Doomsday Clock that character is
Malcolm the psychiatrist son and it's an
ally of Ozymandias for the majority of
it until he switches sides it seems like
they are leaning heavily away from that
book though it would be cool if they
brought that aspect in as it's one of
the best parts of that series it does a
brilliant job of teasing the show and I
can't wait to see if it lives up to the
hype
so what were your thoughts on the teaser
trailer did you enjoy it and what did
you take from it comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and check out my
podcast series watching the Watchmen and
that I do with my friend Tom qui we
break down the entire watchman and
Doomsday Clock run issue-by-issue
analyzing it in great detail and have
interviewed Watchmen colorist John
Higgins on the work so it's a great
lesson that will be linked at the end to
make sure you check it out this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]